salut les menthe à l'eau aujourd'hui on
va faire ni une astuce ni un master
classes ni quoi que ce soit on va jouer
avec votre cerveau et pour les plumes en
tôle et d'entre vous j'ai une petite
annonce à la fin de la vidéo
ce sont des jeux qui vont nous permettre
de comprendre un peu mieux notre cerveau
jeu numéro un
vous allez faire mentalement l'addition
suivante ne trichait pas aller pas très
compliqué fait là normalement mille plus
+1000 plus 30
+1000 +20 plus 1000 +10 est égal à
s'accumulent il pas du tout le résultat
c'est 4100 mais la plupart d'entre vous
ont dû se tromper et se sont fait
absorber par ce qu'on appelle le tunnel
de suffisance notre cerveau une autre
logique adore les sommes arrondi ce qui
fait que 85% à 95% d'entre vous se sont
trompés dans le résultat la première
fois qu'ils font ce test un émoi inclus
je m'étais planté aussi deuxième jeu
vous devez compter en quelques secondes
le nombre de f qui a dans la phrase qui
va s'afficher là maintenant tout de
suite c'est parti maintenant non je fais
pas de bruit
non je ne sais pas vous déconcentrer
attention c'est bientôt maintenant
terminé fini combien il y avait de f
le vrai résultat et 6 et vous en avez
trouvé sûrement moins encore une fois
pour la majorité d'entre vous peut être
pas tout le monde à chaque fois un mais
la majorité en a trouvé moins pourquoi
parce que notre cerveau n'a pas intégré
les off les mots of le cerveau n'intègre
pas les mots courts de liaison en
réalité il est déduit ne lit pas
réellement il déduit l'ensemble de la
phrase je du cerveau numéro 3
je vais afficher un texte à l'écran et
vous devez le lire le plus rapidement
possible à voix haute ou dans votre tête
peu importe mais l'élysée le plus
rapidement et le plus normalement
possible c'est parti maintenant
y a rien d'autre à rajouter à ce jeu
j'espère que ça vous a plu c'est un de
mes trucs préféré à faire avec l'esprit
je m'en étais servi d'ailleurs pour la
communication de mon spectacle en 2014
ce que j'ai trouvé ça passionnant est
vraiment bluffant jeune numéro 4 ce sera
le dernier pour aujourd'hui encore une
fois c'est avec des mots et des lettres
sur une phrase très courte il va
s'afficher à l'écran vous devez
absolument la lire rapidement à voix
haute ou en chuchotant encore une fois
on voulait s'en aller maintenant c'est
facile et voilà là encore de la majorité
des essais les personnes évitent inde
est là parce qu'il y a de là il ya de
marquer il va à la plage
et encore une fois la hausse et a
corrigé la vraie conclusion de ces je
sais qu'il faut pas toujours se fier à
notre mental on a l'impression que notre
mental c'est le truc super puissant et
c'est vraiment ce qu'il ya de plus
important on peut lui faire une
confiance aveugle c'est complètement
faux faut pas toujours se fier à ce
qu'on croit avoir vu à ce qu'on croit
avoir compris est ce qu'on croit avoir
entendu puisque là on l'a vu dans ces
quatre jeux notre cerveau fait des
corrections en permanence il est pas
fiable à 100% de cerveau parce qu'il
veut toujours trouver une cohérence
partout et ça ça fera l'objet d'une
prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère que vous avez joué
le jeu dit moi dans les commentaires là
où vous êtes trompés ou là où vous avez
résisté sans chercher forcément à
résister n'oubliez pas de laisser un
puissant et non trompeur pouce en l'air
vous pouvez aussi partager cette vidéo
pour voir les résultats de vos amis voir
ce que ça leur fait à eux sur les
réseaux sociaux et bien sûr abonnez-vous
à la chaîne avant de partir puisque le
mental drogue c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an depuis le 1er janvier
jusqu'au 31 décembre donc rendez vous
demain à 11h ciao
merci d'être resté après là où trop
alors j'avais une petite annonce à vous
faire souvent dans les messages privés
ou par mail vous me demander où est ce
que je joue mon spectacle je vous le dis
la juste eu rapidement comme ça on n'y
reviendra plus je joue le 23 septembre à
la garenne colombes c'est à côté de
paris c'est la date la plus proche de
paris que je fais avec cette tournée là
avec ce spectacle
l'avantagé d'une tournée c'est que je
fais le spectacle durant une heure et
demie c'est le spectacle en version
entière alors qu'à paris on est obligé
de jouer qu'une heure donc serré gagne
colombes c'est très facile d'accès le
transilien le tramway le bus tout ce que
vous voulez ce sera le spectacle qui
tourne actuellement pas celui que je
suis en train d'écrire pour les
prochaines c'est le spectacle fabien
olicard vous mentalise si vous n'êtes
pas pareil je voulais voir ce spectacle
où le nouveau l'année prochaine
vous pouvez aller sur le site
www.faetd.com préfèrent pour voir toutes
les dates de tournage n'a pas encore
votre ville vous inquiétez pas chaque
semaine on rajoute des nouvelles villes
et ce qui advient après le spectacle sur
la fin de la représentation je suis
toujours disponible pour qu'on puisse se
voir
rendez vous le 23 septembre ou sur une
autre date ciao